il faut cesser de combattre la fatigue
il faut sortir de cette idée que la
seule solution pour pouvoir être bien
dans sa vie c'est de lutter de combattre
la fatigue et si on regardait la fatigue
plutôt comme une alliée un signal qui
vous veut du bien
un signal qui vous dit qu'il est temps
d'arrêter de vous reposer
[Musique]
il faut faire des pauses et faire
plusieurs pauses dans la journée parce
qu'à force de faire des pauses on se
repose
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça veut
dire faire comme l'ensemble des gens qui
prennent une pause pour aller fumer une
clope faire des pauses clopes et si vous
n'êtes pas fumeur vous avez remarqué que
les fumeurs font pas des pauses et bien
fait une pause clope sans club
[Musique]
dès que vous sentez que vous êtes
fatigués vous allez vous coucher
les gens qui dorment beaucoup peuvent se
lever fatigué et des gens qui dorment
peu peuvent se lever en pleine forme le
matin quand vous éveillez ne sautez pas
du dit pressé après avoir entendu un son
strident
ou peut-être le rap le plus agressif qui
soit vous pouvez prendre une musique ou
une lumière si vous avez un ami lumière
qui va vous sortir du sommeil et qui va
peut-être même un moment être un moment
que vous pouvez délectez vous reposer
dès là dès le début de la journée est
une façon de changer votre rapport à la
fatigue vous n'êtes obligé de rien faire
ou si ce n'est de faire rien la
distinction est capitale rien faire
c'est pas si ce passif faire rien ces
actifs nous décidons de faire mes liens
donc abandonné toutes les injonctions
qui sont liées à tout ce que vous pouvez
lire en permanence sur l'idée de du
bien-être de plus en plus je vois des
gens qui s'épuise à vouloir être bien
alors ils font du yoga
ils font de la méditation ils font du
sport à des heures pas possibles
il s'efforce de manger sainement dans
tous les sens alors qu'elle est ils sont
ils s'épuisent en fait à vouloir être
bien et il ya une vraie confusion entre
les êtres bien et bien aller lemire
écoles morning que vous voyez sur
instagram à des photos prix à ben ali
s'est souvent des fautes au programme l
avance ne tombez pas dans les pièges
si ça vous fait du bien de vous lever à
4 heures du matin pour méditer faites le
mais si vous avez envie de dormir à 4
heures et encore à 4h30 et encore à 6h
et mal dormi
[Musique]
enlever toutes les notifications aller
sur vos réseaux sociaux voient aller sur
votre compte mail aller où vous voulez
quand vous le décidez
c'est vous qui tenez le téléphone c'est
pas le téléphone qui vous tient et ne
vous laissez pas le téléphone vous
épuisez vous interrompre en permanence
dans ce que vous êtes en train de faire
parce que de toutes ces micro coupure
n'est une fatigue
c'est tout bête quand on reprend 42 fois
quelque chose on s'est plu à le
reprendre
alors que si on reste concentrés on
l'évacué ont fait plus vite c'est la
technique des feignants les fainéants
sont des gens qui font les choses
intelligemment et de façon consiste
l'invité pas votre téléphone dans votre
champ blessé lui aussi se reposer dans
une autre pièce et de ce fait vous
entrerez dans une relation plus saine
avec votre téléphone portable qui est
une source de fatigue multiples il ya
une autre fatick il faut explorer qu'est
la bonne fatigue la fatigue qu'il y ait
à ce qui compte pour soi donc par
exemple faire du sport c'est une fatigue
qui se dissipe dès lors qu'on a récupéré
au bout de quelques minutes après allez
une expo de se nourrir de belles choses
aller au concert se promener simplement
prendre un temps vous êtes obligés de
manger devant netflix en regardant le
quatrième épisode 2010 vous avez raté le
soir avant et bien c'est tout simplement
déjà un moment où vous allez entrer en
relation avec ce qui con pour vous
il faut absolument ralentir si vous
voulez profiter de la vie observez ce
qui se passe autour de vous ne pas vous
épuiser à être comme le hamster qui
courent et qui n'observent absolument
rien ralentissez ralentissez dans deux
dimensions
la première compte vous vous alimentez
si vous voulez cesser de vous remplir et
si vous voulez éveiller vos sens
il suffit de ralentir et de mâcher de
manger plus lentement l'autre point
c'est quand vous rentrez chez vous le
soir par exemple et que vous êtes
fatigués parce que vous avez passé une
journée difficile éreintante pour ne pas
cumuler les fatiguer ne pas déverser la
pâte xo le reste des gens qui vivent
avec vous et bien prenez un temps pour
laisser la fatigue s'évacuer par vos
pieds en râlant qui sont vous pouvez
même frotté un peu les pieds sur le
bitume relâché vos épaules sentir à quel
point vous laisser cette fatigue tomber
se dissiper nous avons gagné en deux
siècles
près de trois fois le temps que nous
allions pro vivre il faut se rappeler
qu'au xviiie siècle l'espérance de vie
était de moins de 30 ans en france 27
ans
aujourd'hui on frôle les 90 ans et
pourtant on continue de courir comme des
apps faire comme des hamsters après le
temps perdu
hors du temps on en a